The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right,
let's get started.
I am Erik Demaine.
You can call me Erik.
Today we're going
to do another divide
and conquer algorithm called
the fast Fourier transform.
It's probably the most
taught algorithm at MIT.
It's used in all
sorts of contexts,
especially digital
signal processing
like MP3 compression,
and all sorts of things.
But we're going to
think about it today
in the context of divide
and conquer and polynomials.
So let me remind you-- I
mean, this class is all
about polynomial time, but
usually with polynomial time
we only care about
the lead term.
Today-- and today
only, pretty much--
we're going to be thinking about
all the terms in a polynomial.
So I'll talk about
polynomials mostly a and b.
You have a constant
term, and then
a linear term, and a quadratic
term, and so on up to-- I
will say that there are
n terms-- which means
the last one is a n minus 1.
Normally the degree the
polynomial here is n minus 1.
I wish the degree was defined
to be n here, but whatever.
That's-- I'm not-- I can't
change the definitions
in algebra.
So this is the
traditional algebraic way
of thinking about a polynomial.
Of course, you can write
it with summation notation.
akx to the k, k
equals 0 to n minus 1.
We'll jump back and
forth between them.
I'm also going to introduce a
vector notation for polynomials
because-- so the ai's are
real numbers, typically.
We might change
that at some point,
but usually-- a common
reason-- maybe you
don't care much
about polynomials,
but you definitely
care about vectors.
Any kind of
one-dimensional data set
is a string of real
numbers, like if you're
sampling audio--
like right now we're
recording this
microphone-- you're
seeing lots of different--
the movement of the membrane
in this microphone over time.
You're sampling-- whatever--
40,000 times the second.
Each one you're
measuring a real number
about where that thing is.
That is a sequence
of real numbers.
Now, you can convert it into
a polynomial if you want.
They're the same thing.
x is not necessarily
meaningful here.
We really care about
other coefficients.
Now, given such a
polynomial there
are three typical
things we want to do.
So these are the
operations on polynomials.
I'll say why we want
to do them in a second.
So the obvious one, if
you do care about x,
is some kind of evaluation.
So maybe I give you
a polynomial-- a
of x-- and I give you a
number-- let's call it x0--
and I want to compute
what is a of x0.
So if I plug in-- x here
is a general variable,
but if I give you an
actual real number,
say, for the x's, what
does that add up to?
So, how would you
solve evaluation
before we go to the
other operations?
There's an obvious way.
We, you know-- you compute
all the terms and add them up,
but if you do that
naively, computing
x to the k-- in this form,
maybe-- computing x to the k
maybe takes k
multiplications, and so
the total runtime
of the quadratic,
but we can do better than that.
I know it's 11 o'clock-- too
early in the morning think.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When you've already
calculated x to the i,
you can calculate x to the
i plus 1 by multiplying it.
ERIK DEMAINE: Good.
Once you've computed
x to the k, you
can compute x to the k plus
1 with one multiplication,
and so you can compute all
x to n's in linear time
and then you're basically
doing a dot product between x
to the k's and the a vector.
Cool, my first Frisbee.
So, that's one way to do it.
There's a slightly
slicker way to write
it called Horner's
Rule, but it's
doing exactly the same
thing that you said.
It's a-- this is just a nice
algebraic way of writing it.
a of x is the same as a0 plus
x times a1 plus x times a2
plus, and so on.
x times a n minus 1, and then
lots of-- close parentheses.
So this is, of course,
equivalent to that expression
by the law of distribution,
and this is essentially doing
the x-products one at a time.
So, this is clearly order n
additions and multiplication,
so we get order n time.
In this lecture,
time is the number
of arithmetic operations.
That's our model.
Assume it takes constant
time to multiply or add
two real numbers.
OK.
Cool.
So, evaluation-- that's easy.
Linear time, for today, is good.
Quadratic is bad.
We want to beat quadratic.
OK, second thing you might
want to do with polynomials
is add them.
The third thing
is multiply them.
So, we're given two
polynomials-- a of x and b
of x-- and we want to compute
a new polynomial-- c of x--
that is the summation.
How do you define the summation?
Well, you would like
c of x to equal a of x
plus b of x for all x.
That's the definition.
Of course, we can do it
algebraically as well
because these are
numbers in the end--
for any x this
evaluates to a number--
so if we add two
polynomials of this form--
one with ai's, one with the b
i's-- all we're doing is adding
corresponding ai's and b i's.
So, this is easy.
We just need ck to equal
ak plus bk for all k.
So, again, linear
time-- no problem.
Third operation is the exciting
one, the hard one to get good,
otherwise this lecture would be
over in a couple more minutes.
So multiplication-- same deal.
We're given a of x
and b of x, and we
want to convert that into
some c of x that, for all x,
evaluates to the product
of those two polynomials.
How do we do this?
We can't just multiply
corresponding ak's and bk's.
In fact, if you take
a big thing like this
and you multiply it by
corresponding big thing-- eh,
let's do it.
This doesn't look like fun.
We get-- let's see.
So, the constant term is just
the product-- that's easy,
the constant terms--
but then, if I
take this product or this
product, I get linear terms.
So it's going to be
a1b0 plus a0b1 times x,
and then there's
a quadratic term
which I get from-- switch
colors-- this and this
and this.
So there's three
things times x squared,
and that's where I get tired.
I'm going to switch to
the summation notation.
I didn't go to high school, but
I assume in high school algebra
you learn this.
ck is the sum of
j equals 0 to k.
ajbk minus j.
That's the general form
because aj came from an x
to the j term, bk minus j came
from x to the k minus j term.
When you multiply those
together, you get x to the k,
so this is the
coefficient of x to the k.
Cool?
So, that's what we'd
like to compute.
Given a and b we want to
compute this polynomial c.
How long does it take?
We have to do this for all k.
So, to compute the k-th
term takes order k time,
so the total time is n squared.
So, that's not good
for this lecture.
We want to do better.
In fact, today we
will achieve n log n.
That's our goal-- polynomial
multiplication in n log n.
Why do we care about
polynomial multiplication?
Because it's equivalent
to another operation which
we use all the time in
digital signal processing,
image editing, all sorts
of different things,
which is convolution.
Convolution is usually thought
of as an operation on vectors.
So, remember this
vector notation,
where we're just thinking
about the coefficients.
x's are kind of irrelevant.
We're just thinking about
a sequence of real numbers.
So, maybe that sequence of
real numbers for a represents
waveform.
Maybe this is the
audio I'm speaking now.
And then I take
some other waveform.
Here I have a Gaussian
function-- e to the minus
x squared-- and I want to
take-- for all possible shifts
of this Gaussian
I want to compute
the dot product
between the blackboard
and the piece of paper.
That's some kind of
smoothing function,
if I wanted to clean up
noise or something like that.
You can do the same thing
on a two-dimensional image.
It's a little harder
to think about,
but you can map a
two-dimensional image
to a one-dimensional vector.
And you have a
two-dimensional Gaussian--
if you ever do Gaussian
blur in Photoshop
this is what you're
doing-- a convolution--
and it's used to pretend that
your lens is out of focus
when you do that.
It's done in audio processing,
and all sorts of things.
So, formally, you're
given two vectors
and you want to take all
possible shifts of one vector
and take the dot product
with the other one.
I have that written down.
I just-- dot product, same
thing as inner product,
which just means multiply
corresponding positions
and add them up.
And, if you ignore
this minus sign,
that's exactly
what this is doing.
This is taking aj versus
bk, pretend it's plus j.
So, that's the bj vector, but
with all possible shifts k.
We compute this for all k.
That's really cool.
We're going to compute
it in n log n time.
All different n shifts of b will
take the dot product with a.
It's kind of magical
because it looks
like you're doing
n squared work,
but we will do it
in n log n time.
The only issue is we
have to reverse b.
Then the minus signs
turn into plus signs.
And there's some
boundary conditions,
but it's basically the same.
If we can solve
polynomial multiplication,
we can solve convolution.
Cool?
So, that's why we care
about multiplication.
So, how are we
going to solve this?
What I'd like to do is talk
about alternate representations
of polynomials.
That's the next thing here.
We just did operations.
Let's talk about
different representations.
So, we talked about this
one representation--
it's one way to
represent polynomial--
but it's not the only one.
You probably know others.
So, on the one hand we
have representation a
is a coefficient vector.
So we can write down the ai's.
That was just one way to
represent a polynomial.
Can anyone give me another
way to represent a polynomial?
I have two ways in mind.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Generating function?
ERIK DEMAINE:
Generating function.
Isn't that the same-- oh,
I guess in principle you
could imagine writing a
recurrence on the generating
function or something.
It's plausible.
In general, generating
functions are
polynomials if you know
what that-- they are cool.
So it doesn't quite
answer the question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Representation.
ERIK DEMAINE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Points?
ERIK DEMAINE: Point
representation, yeah.
I call them samples.
I'm going to put that under
C. A bunch of samples, a bunch
of points on the polynomial.
So like xk, yk for-- how many
do we need-- I think n minus 1
should do it.
We'll check.
Yep.
And if we are told
that a of xk equals yk,
and we're told that all
the xk's are distinct,
then this uniquely
determines the polynomial.
You have a degree n
minus one polynomial,
and you have n samples.
There's only one
polynomial that passes
through all those points.
It's a consequence of the
fundamental theorem of algebra
that gives you uniqueness.
Existence, I think, was
proved by Legendre in 1700s,
1800s-- a long time ago.
This is good.
This is what we're going to use.
There's another answer.
I should give you
a Frisbee first.
You look so excited.
Just wait till I hit you,
then you'll be less excited.
OK, so.
Samples, coefficients,
anything else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Roots?
ERIK DEMAINE: Roots, yeah.
Roots is the other
answer I was looking for,
but it's not going to be so good
algorithmically, as we'll see.
Sorry.
So, I can give you
a sequence of roots.
This is the fundamental
theorem of algebra
that every polynomial
is uniquely determined
by its set of roots.
If you allow roots
with multiplicity then
every polynomial of degree
n has exactly n roots.
So, this would be some sequence
of r1 up to rn minus 1,
and the polynomial would
be given as-- you actually
need a constant multiplier--
but x minus r0, x minus r1.
That would be polynomial.
The trouble with roots
is that if I give you
a coefficient vector and I
want to compute the roots,
not only is it hard to do, it's
impossible to do in our model.
If you're only allowed to
add, subtract, multiply,
divide, take square
roots, take k-th roots,
there is no way to solve
a polynomial of degree
5 or larger.
There's the quadratic formula,
cubic formula, quartic formula.
There is no quintic formula.
That's an old result. 1800s.
So, going from coefficient
vector to roots
takes infinite time.
It's not so good.
And, in particular, if we
think about our operations,
addition becomes
really difficult.
Multiplication is easy if I
have two polynomials represented
as a sequence of roots.
I want to multiply them.
That's just concatenating
the vectors--
taking union the vectors
of their root lists.
So that's cool.
I'm multiplying
the c's, I guess.
But addition is really
hard because addition
is sort of fundamentally
about coefficient vectors.
And then, once
you go there-- you
can go from roots to coefficient
vectors and add them up,
but then there's no
relation between the roots
of the sum of the
polynomials versus the roots
of the original.
I don't know for sure
that that's impossible.
It's definitely very, very
hard, probably impossible.
Let me draw a little table.
Each of these representations
has some advantages
and a disadvantage in terms
of these three operations.
So, on the one hand,
we have the algorithms
we care about-- evaluation,
addition, and multiplication--
and on the other axis we have
our representations, which
are coefficient vectors,
roots, and samples.
You'll see why I chose
this order in a moment.
It makes for a
nice, pretty matrix.
We've talked about almost
every cell in this matrix,
but let me just summarize.
We started out just thinking
about coefficient vector,
and evaluation was linear time.
Addition was linear time.
Multiplication, so
far, was quadratic,
although our goal
is to make n log n.
For roots, I just said
multiplication is easy.
That's linear time,
addition is really hard--
like, infinite time--
and evaluation,
I guess that's linear time.
In fact, the way it's
written, you only
have a linear number
of subtractions
and multiplications, so it's
really easy to evaluate.
And then sample vectors-- we
haven't talked much about that.
The idea is, suppose you're
given two polynomials with
the same xk's.
We're going to fix xk's.
All we need is that
they're distinct.
So xk could equal
k, for example,
just a bunch of integers.
And then we are told what
polynomial a evaluates
to at every xk, and we're
told what polynomial
b evaluates to at every xk.
So, we're given some yk's
and some zk's, and then we
want to compute, say, the sum
or the product of those two
vectors.
What do we do?
Just add or multiply the
corresponding yk and zk's,
because if we're
told we want c of x
to equal a of x times b of
x, or c of x to equal a of x
plus b of x for all x, Well, now
we know what x's we care about.
We just do it at the xk's.
That's what we're
told for a and for b,
and so to compute c of
xk it's just the sum
or the product of yk and zk.
So multiplication is really
easy in the sample view,
and this is why we are
going to use this view.
We're also going to use this
view because, as we'll see,
there's a problem.
Addition is easy,
multiplication is easy,
evaluation is annoying.
I can evaluate a of
x at xk for any k,
but I can't evaluate it at
some arbitrary value of x.
That's annoying.
I'm told at these
finite sample points,
but now I have to
somehow interpolate.
This is called
polynomial interpolation,
well studied in numerical
analysis and so on.
You can do it, but it takes
quadratic time, in general.
The best known
algorithms are quadratic.
So, this is bad, this
is bad, and this is bad,
so no representation is perfect.
Life sucks.
What we'd like is to
get the best-- now
this one is really hard to work
with because converting inter
roots is impossible in
an arithmetic model,
so we're going to focus
on column A and column
C. We kind of like to take
the min of those two columns.
We won't quite get that.
What we will get is an
algorithm for converting
between these two
representations in n log n
time-- it's not quite
linear, but close--
and once we can do that,
if we want to multiply two
things in the coefficient land
we can convert to sample land,
do it in linear time,
and then convert back.
So that's the magical
transformation
we're going to cover, and it
is called the fast Fourier
transfer.
Fast Fourier transform
is the algorithm.
Discrete Fourier transform
is that transformation
mathematically.
Cool.
So the whole name of
the game is converting
from coefficient representation
to samples, or vice versa.
Turns out they're
almost the same,
though that won't be
obvious for a long time--
till the end of the class.
Any questions before we proceed?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
multiply repetitions,
why not we evaluate a and
b first then multiply?
ERIK DEMAINE: Ah.
So, OK, the question
is, if I want
to-- we'll get
there in a second--
but if I want to
multiply, and it's
so easy to do in sample land,
why don't I just sample a and b
and then multiply them?
That's right, but [? effect ?]
sampling is not so easy.
It takes quadratic time.
Let's go there now.
Because we have n samples to do,
each one will cost linear time.
Remember, to evaluate a
polynomial takes linear time.
If you want to think
of it in a matrix--
let's enter the matrix--
then we get a big matrix.
So we're given the
xi's and we just
want to evaluate a given
polynomial whose coefficients
are given by a0,
a1, a2, and minus 1.
Our goal is to compute
the yi's-- y0, y1, y2,
to yn minus 1-- and if you
know a matrix-vector product,
you take this row
with that column.
You take the dot
product that multiplies
corresponding entries.
You get y0.
That is the definition of
the polynomial evaluation.
I'm just going to write
a bunch of these rows
so you get the pattern.
Pretty simple.
This is called the
Vandermonde matrix.
I'll call it V. And in general--
I don't have room for it,
so let me go--
In general, if we look at
V ij, it's just-- sorry.
You may notice I'm not
using the letter i.
We will get to why in a moment.
V jk.
Row j, column k.
That's going to be x
sub j to the power k.
That's the Vandermonde matrix.
We can compute it
in quadratic time.
It has quadratic entries.
We can use the trick
we suggested earlier--
compute each term
from the previous one
by multiplying by
xj-- and then we
want to compute this
matrix-vector product,
and you can clearly do
it in quadratic time--
I'm just computing each
thing correspondingly--
and that's sort of
the best you can
do without any
further assumptions.
So this takes-- if
I want to compute
this product, that's the
coefficients to samples
problem.
This is the same thing as
computing V times the A vector,
so this is a matrix-vector
multiplication,
which takes n squared time.
OK?
On the other hand--
so, that's a problem
because we're trying to beat
quadratic multiplication,
so if we spend quadratic
time to convert over here
it doesn't matter if
this is linear time.
There are two problems.
One is that conversion
costs too much.
The other is we don't yet
know how to convert backwards.
But this matrix
field gives us also
the reverse transformation.
If we want to convert
samples to coefficients,
this is-- the best notation
I know is from MATLAB.
How many people know MATLAB?
A bunch.
So for you, it's V
backslash A, but usually
in linear algebra
like 18.06 you see
you have some matrix V
times some unknown vector--
usually it's called x,
here it's called a--
and you know the
right-hand side.
You want to solve for this.
How do you do it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Multiply
by the inverse?
ERIK DEMAINE: Multiply
by the inverse.
Yeah.
How do you do it in
computer science?
AUDIENCE: Gaussian elimination.
ERIK DEMAINE:
Gaussian elimination.
Turns out inverse is
the right answer here,
but Gaussian elimination
would be the standard way
to solve a linear
system like that.
The trouble with
Gaussian elimination
is it takes cubic time
in its normal form.
In this case it's a
little bit special
because this matrix
is essentially fixed.
The xi's don't need to change.
It could be xi is just i
or something, so we can--
in this case it's
a little better
to compute the inverse first.
So we could also just
do v inverse times a.
From a numerical analysis
standpoint this is very bad,
but don't worry
about it for now.
We're going to get a
better algorithm today.
Anyway, it doesn't
involve matrices at all,
but the nice thing
is, if computing
the inverse, that
takes n cubed time,
but you only have to do it once.
So if you have to
do this many times
you can do this product
in n squared time.
You just have to maintain that
v inverse once and for all.
OK, great.
So, we've got
quadratic algorithms
to go back and forth between
these representations.
That, at least,
tells us it's doable,
but we, of course,
need better than
quadratic to improve on the
naive multiplication algorithm,
so that's what
we're going to do.
In general, we
can't do any better,
but we have one freedom,
which is we have said nothing
about the x case.
We can choose them to be
whatever we want them to be.
I keep saying xk equals k.
That seems fine.
It's actually really bad choice
for a reason we will get to,
but there is a choice where,
magically, this transformation
becomes easy and you can
do it in n log n time.
Before we get there,
I want to give you
some motivation for how
this could possibly work.
As you might expect, even just
from that n log n running time,
we're going to be using
divide and conquer,
so let's just think about how
divide and conquer could work.
I'm going to show
you an idea and then
we'll figure out how that
idea could possibly work.
It doesn't work at
the moment, but we
will be able to choose
the xk so that it works.
So, let's say the goal-- I mean,
what we want to do is compute
this v times a.
I'm going to convert-- think of
that back into polynomial land.
So our goal is to compute a
of x for all x in some set x.
This is taking a
bunch of samples.
Set x is just a set
of the xk's, but I'm
going to change that set in
a moment using recursion.
So the input to this algorithm
is a polynomial a of x,
and it's a set
capital X of positions
that I'd like to evaluate
that polynomial at.
This is clearly more
general than the problem
we're trying to solve, and I'm
going to solve it with divide
and conquer.
In divide and conquer
there are three steps.
Divide, conquer, and combine.
Let's start with divide.
Here's the big idea.
I would say there
are two natural ways
to divide a vector.
One is in the middle,
that's what we've always
seen with merge sort and
convex hull from last time,
but there's another way
which will work better here,
which is the even entries
and the odd entries.
So I'm going to divide into
even and odd coefficients.
Let me write that down.
One of them is called a sub
even of x-- that's a polynomial.
It's going to have half
the degree, so it's
going to be sum from k
equals 0 to-- I wrote n here,
but I think I want something
like n over 2 minus 1,
n minus 1 over 2, one of those
things-- of a to k x to the k.
So, really, what I want--
which is easier to write-- is,
in the vector notation, I
want all the even entries.
I won't try to figure
out what the last one is,
but it's roughly n over 2-ish.
I'll just write that.
You can go a little bit extra.
It's fine if you define a sub
n to be 0, and a sub n plus 1
to be zero, and all those to be
0, those terms will disappear.
So the key thing here is
I'm taking the even entries,
but I don't have 2k up here.
This is the x to the 0 term.
This is the x to the 1 term.
This is the x to the 2 term.
So there's a difference between
x to the k's and the sub 2k,
but, I mean, just think
about it in vector form.
Don't worry about
the algebra for now.
We're going to have to
worry about it in a second,
but, intuitively,
what I want to do
is extract from the vector
of all the ai's these two
vectors-- the odd
coefficients in order
and the even
coefficients in order--
but I'm going to need the
algebraic form in a moment
for the combined step.
It should be 2k plus 1 x to k.
That's step one.
Easy to do.
Linear time, of course.
Let's jump ahead to
step three, combine.
In order to compute
a of x from-- what
I'd like to do is
recursively compute a even
of x and a odd of x
for some values x.
It's not going to be x and x.
It's going to be some other set.
Let's think about
how I can compute
a of x given some solutions
to a even of x and a odd of x.
So this is step three, combine.
So I would like
a of x over here,
and I want a even of something
and a odd of something
and something in here.
Anyone see the algebra?
Maybe start with this?
I hear a mumble.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: x squared.
ERIK DEMAINE: x squared.
Exactly.
Time for a purple one.
I'm getting better.
Why x squared?
Because we have
this mismatch here.
We have a sub 2k.
We want x to the 2k.
How could we do that?
Well, we could put x squared to
the 2k, and x squared to the k
is the same thing
as x to the 2k.
And so magically this
transforms into the even entries
of a of x.
That's half of them.
We do the same thing for the
odd ones and we're almost there.
Now we have a sub 2k plus 1
times x to the 2k, no plus 1.
So how can I add a plus 1?
AUDIENCE: Multiply by x.
ERIK DEMAINE:
Multiply by x here.
Take the whole
thing, multiply by x,
then I get all of the
odd terms of a of x.
I add these together.
I get a of x.
I mean, you could prove
this more carefully,
but that's just algebra to
see that this is correct.
Once you have this, it
tells you what I need to do
is compute a even of x
squared for all x in x,
so this is 4x and x.
There's a for loop for you.
So that's going to
take linear time.
If I already know this value
and I already know this value,
I do one multiplication,
one addition, and boom.
I get a of x.
So in the conquer step I
want to recursively compute--
I think I'll call it-- a even
of y, and a odd of y for y
in x squared.
x squared is the set of
squares of all numbers in x.
So I'm changing my set x.
I started with a
polynomial a and a set x.
Recursively, I'm doing
a different polynomial
of half the degree-- half
the number of terms--
but with a different
set of the same size.
I started with x.
x squared has the
same size as x, right?
So let's try to figure out how
fast or slow this algorithm is.
But that isn't
divide and conquer.
That is going to be
our golden ticket.
It's pretty simple, but we're
going to need another trick.
So I'm going to
write a recurrence.
Now, this recurrence
depends on two things.
One is how many terms are there
in a that we've been calling n?
And the other is how many
numbers are there in x?
How many different places do I
have to evaluate my polynomial?
So we've got t of n, and I
always call it size of x.
So divide and conquer goes
hand-in-hand with recurrences.
Generally you've got
the recursive part,
so that's just how big
are the subproblems.
How many are there?
There are two subproblems.
They have half the
size in terms of n,
but they have the same
size in terms of x.
So, all right, 2
times-- because there's
two subproblems-- each with
size n over 2 and size x, plus
what goes here is however much
it costs to do the divide step,
plus however much it costs
to do the combined step-- all
the non-recursive parts.
So this is just partitioning
the vectors-- linear scan,
linear time.
This is-- we talked
about it-- it's
a constant number of arithmetic
operations for each x.
So this cause-order x time,
this cause-order n time.
So, in general, we get n plus x.
Now, this is, again,
not a recurrent solvable
by the master method because
it has two variables.
So usually when you're faced
with this sort of thing,
you want to do back of
the envelope picture.
Draw a recursion tree.
That's a good way to go.
So at the root-- now, I know
that initially x equals n.
When I start out I
have n coefficients,
I have n different positions
I want to evaluate them
at because that's
what I want to do
to do this conversion from
coefficients to samples.
So at the root of the recursion
tree I'm just going to write n.
Order n work to get started
and to do the recursions.
There are two recursive calls.
One has som-- both have
size n over 2 in terms of a,
and they have the same
x-- which is also known
as n-- in those two recursions.
So in fact, the linear
work here will be n and n,
and then we'll get n and n.
x never goes down,
so x always remains
n-- the original value of n.
This is a bad recurrence.
There are n-- sorry,
there are log n levels.
That's the good news.
Once we get down to constant
size we can kind of stop.
When there's only
one coefficient
I know how to evaluate the
polynomial with just a 0.
That's easy.
So down at the bottom
here, at the last level--
this is the height log n--
the last level is just, again,
going to be a whole bunch
of n's-- all the same n.
Here n is the original
value of x because we
haven't changed that.
How many n's are
there down here?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the log n.
ERIK DEMAINE: 2 to the
log n, also known as n.
Good.
So we had-- because
we had log n levels,
we had binary branching, so
it's 2 to the number of levels,
which is just n.
So this is n squared.
All this work, still n squared.
Clearly what we need is
for x to get smaller, too.
If x-- if, in this
recursion-- let
me, in red, draw the recursion
I would like to have.
If x became x over
2 here, that's
the only change we'd need.
Then n and x change in
exactly the same way,
and so then we can
just forget about x--
it's going to be the same as n.
Then we get 2 times n
over 2 plus order n.
Look familiar?
It is our bread and
butter recurrence--
merge sort recurrence.
That's n log n.
That's what we need to do.
Somehow, when we convert
our set x to x squared,
I want x to get smaller.
Is that at all plausible?
Let's think about it.
What's the base case?
To keep things simple let's say
the base case when x equals 1,
I'll just let x be-- let's say
I want to compute my a at 1.
Keep it simple.
What if I want two values in x?
I'd like to have the
feature that when
I square all the values in
x-- so I want two values,
but when I square them
I only have one value.
Solve for x.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Negative 1 and 1?
ERIK DEMAINE: Negative 1 and 1.
Whew, tough one.
Ehh.
Not bad.
Good catch.
Negative 1 and 1.
That could work.
What are negative 1 and 1?
They're the square roots of 1.
Negative 1 squared
is 1, 1 squared is 1.
There's two square
roots for every number.
Two square roots
for every number.
Interesting.
So that means, if I just
keep taking square roots,
when I square them it
collapses by a factor of 2.
Let me go to another board
and define something.
You're all anticipating
what's going to happen,
but I'm going to
say, a collapsing
set x-- or, a set is collapsing
if either the size of x squared
is the size of x divided
by 2, and, recursively,
x squared is collapsing.
So I need this to work all
the way down the recursion.
Or I need a base case,
which is just x equals 1.
There's a single item in x.
So I happened to start
with x equals the item 1.
It didn't have to be 1.
It could have been 7.
It couldn't be 0 because 0--
you won't get two numbers.
There's only one
square root of 0.
OK, so I lied a little bit.
Other than 0, every number
has exactly two square roots,
so what's the square
root of negative 1?
AUDIENCE: i.
ERIK DEMAINE: i.
So complex numbers.
If I take square roots of these
guys I get i and negative i,
and again I get minus 1 and 1.
That's when x equals 4.
Turns out this is only going
to work for powers of 2,
but, hey, if n isn't
a power of 2 just
round up to the next power of 2.
That only hurts me
by a factor of 2.
Complex numbers.
Every time I said real
number in the past,
pretend I said complex number.
Everything I said is still true.
Actually, the root
thing is only true
when you allow complex numbers.
Some polynomials
have complex roots,
so pretend I said complex.
We're going to need
complex numbers.
This is why.
Because, when we'd start
taking square roots,
we immediately get
complex numbers.
Next would be x equals 8.
Square root of i.
Square root of i-- let's
see if I can do it--
should be root 2 over
2 times 1 plus i.
And then this one is just
the-- square root of negative i
is going to be root 2
over 2 times 1 minus i,
and then we have
all our old guys.
Oh, and then I could
write plus or minus
in front of each of these.
I was like, there weren't
enough terms there.
Now I've got eight-- sorry,
I've got four numbers here.
I've got four numbers there.
How in the world
could I remember this?
Maybe I memorized it.
No, I didn't memorize it.
It's actually really
easy to figure this out
if you know geometry.
Geometry.
Let's do geometry over here.
It's convenient.
I'm actually a geometer.
You know, complex numbers
have two parts, right?
The real part and
the complex part.
I'm going to draw that in what's
called the complex plane, where
we draw the real
part here, and I
guess it's usually called the
imaginary part on the y-axis.
Every point in this plane is
a complex number, and vice
versa-- the same thing.
So what did we start with?
We started with the number 1.
Number 1 will be here.
It has no imaginary
part, so it's
on the x-axis-- this is
the real line down here--
and it's at position 1, which
I'm going to just define
to be right there.
Then we've got negative 1.
That's over here.
Then we got i.
That's here, 1 times i.
Then we've got negative i.
That's here.
Then we've got root 2
over 2 times i plus 1.
That's here.
Root 2 over 2 by root 2 over 2.
What is a property of root 2
over 2 comma root 2 over 2?
It has distance exactly
1 to the origin.
If I draw this triangle,
root 2 over 2, root 2 over 2.
I square this.
I get a half.
I square this I get a half.
I add them together, I get what?
Take the square root, I still
get 1, so this distance is 1.
Interesting.
And then I got the negative
of that, which is over here,
and a negative of that.
Then this is the-- with a
negative-- did I get it wrong?
Yep, sorry.
It doesn't matter, but I'll
think of it as i minus-- killed
a chalk-- i minus 1.
It's the same because I
have the plus and minus,
but I like the geometry.
So this point is negative root
2 over 2 by root 2 over 2,
and then there's the
negative over here.
What property do
these points have?
I heard a word.
AUDIENCE: Unit circle?
ERIK DEMAINE: Unit circle.
Good.
Who said unit circle?
Nice.
It's a unit circle, right?
Clearly that deserves
a Frisbee end.
Unit circle.
Hm.
Circle.
It seem good.
What's going on here
is I took this number.
I claimed it was
the square root of i
because it turns out, if you
take points on the unit circle
in the complex plane,
when you square
a number it's like doubling the
angle relative to the x-axis.
This is angle 0.
This is angle-- what do
you call it-- 45 degrees.
This is angle 90 degrees.
So when I square this
number I get 90 degrees.
That's why this number
is a square root of i.
I probably should have
labeled some of these.
This is i.
This is minus i.
This is minus 1, and this is 1.
In general, we get something
called-- so these are
called the n-th roots of unity.
Unity is just a
fancy word for 1.
1 is here, and first we
computed the square roots of 1.
They were minus 1 and 1.
Then we computed the
fourth roots of 1.
All of these numbers, if
you take the fourth power,
you get 1.
Then we computed the
eighth roots of 1.
All of these numbers, if
you take the 8th power,
you get 1 again.
So, in general,
n-th roots of unity.
We're going to assume
n is a power of 2,
but this notion actually
makes sense for any n.
And they're just uniformly
spaced around the circle,
and if you know some geometry
and how it relates to trig,
you know that a general
point on the circle
is cos theta comma sine theta.
x-coordinate is cos theta.
y-coordinate is sine theta.
This is also a funny notation
for complex numbers--
not so funny, this is the
geometric interpretation
of cos theta plus i sine theta.
And if I want them uniformly
spaced around the circle,
and I want to include
this point-- also known
as theta equals 0-- because
when theta equals 0,
cos theta is 1, sine theta 0.
So I want to say 4
theta equals to 0,
and then-- here I'm going
to get fancy-- tau over n
to tau over n up to n
minus 1 over n times tau.
What's tau?
AUDIENCE: 2pi.
ERIK DEMAINE: 2pi, thank you.
This is modern notation just
over the last couple years.
I believe in tau so much I
got it tattooed on my arm.
Tau is the fundamental constant.
Screw pi.
None of that 3 and change.
Six and change is where it's at.
So tau.
Clearly this is much nicer.
Tau over n, not 2pi over n.
Tau is a whole circle.
This is one n-th of a circle,
2n-ths of a circle, n minus 1
over n-ths of a circle.
I didn't do n n-ths of a
circle because that's also
the same as 0.
Now, why did I
introduce this notation?
Because there's this
other great thing
called Euler's formula,
which is that this
equals e to the i theta.
Double check.
It's so rare that I get
to do real calculus.
This is Euler's
formula-- e for Euler--
another number-- 2 and change.
e to the i-- this is funny
because it's complex-- times
theta is equal to cos
theta plus i sine theta.
This is the relation between
exponentials and trigonometry.
That's a big thing Euler did.
Cool.
So what?
Because this lets
us understand how
squares work-- not squares the
shape, squares the operation.
When I take squares-- so
if I take e to the i theta,
this is one of my
roots of unity.
Let me expand out what theta is.
So theta is some k
times tau over n.
Let's do it this way first.
So in reality we have k tau
over n, but when I square it,
that's the same thing as
putting the 2 right here.
This is the same thing
as e to i times 2 theta.
Bingo.
I get what I was claiming, that
if I start at some angle theta
relative to the x-axis,
when I square the number
I just double the angle.
This is why.
This is obvious just
from regular algebra.
And then this thing,
Euler's formula,
tells me that corresponds to
doubling the angle on a circle.
So it only works with
points on a circle.
So when I go here I get e to
the i2k times tau over n--
twice as far around circle.
All right.
Fine.
What happens if I take this
number and I square it?
This has a really big angle.
This is 1/2 plus 1/8, whatever
that is-- 5/8 times tau.
When I double that
angle I go to here.
Now, this, you might
call it, 10/8, or you
might also call it 1/4 because
when you go around the circle
you stay on the circle.
So there's another
thing going on,
which is really-- this is e to
the i times 2 theta mod tau.
Usually we think of mods
relative to integers,
but what I mean is every time
I add a multiple of tau nothing
changes.
If I go around the circle five
times and then do something,
it's the same as just
doing the something.
So I kind of need that.
And this is true because
e to the i tau equals 1.
You may know it as e to
the i pi equals negative 1,
but clearly this is a superior
formula-- so superior I got
it tattooed on my other arm.
[LAUGHTER]
It's amazing what you can
do with a laser printer
and a temporary tattoo kit.
Sadly, these won't last, but
definitely try it at home.
Cool.
So e to the i tau equals
1, so going around
in circles-- same thing as not.
All right.
So you can draw on this
picture for every number, what
is its square?
And, in general, if you
look at these four guys,
their squares are just
going to be these two guys.
If you look at these
four guys, their squares
are going to be among
these four guys.
So I started with 8 guys.
I square them, I get 4.
I square them, I get 2.
I square them, I get 1.
That's how we
constructed it, but you
can see it works not
only for this 8-point set
that we constructed
sort of by hand,
but it works for the
n-th roots of unity.
As long as n is a power
of 2 this set of points
will be collapsing.
So if n is the power of
2 for some integer k,
then n-th roots of
unity are collapsing
according to this definition.
And that's what we want.
Then this divide and conquer
algorithm runs in n log n time
because every time
we square the set x,
we reduce its size
by a factor of 2.
We get t of n equals 2
times t of n over 2 plus n.
Plus order n and
that's order n log n.
And so this whole thing we
compute-- in other words,
we set xk to be e to
the ik tau over n.
Now, I guess I should
say how to compute that,
but let's just say that's
given to you for free.
It takes constant time to
compute each roots of unity.
In fact, again, we
only need to do this
once and for all
for each value of n,
so you can think of it as just
being part of the algorithm.
These are the xk's we use.
I said xk could be anything
we want as long as they're all
different, so I'm
going to choose them
to be n uniformly spaced points
around the complex unit circle.
And then magically this
algorithm runs in n log n time.
It's pretty cool.
Intuitively, you think of
real numbers x squared,
of course it has
the same sides as x.
But once you go
to complex numbers
there's this nifty
trick where you
start with one
n-th of the circle
and you'd uniformly space
points after the first level
of recursion.
You only have to be
dealing with n over two
of those points,
namely the even ones,
also known as the n over
[? 2th ?] roots of unity.
And after the next
level of recursion
is the n over fourth
roots of unity.
And so on.
So this recursion
is well defined.
When you have a vector
of size n you just
have to deal with the n-th roots
of unity, and you're happy.
That is fast Fourier transform.
That algorithm with
these xi's is FFT.
So let me write this somewhere.
It kind of snuck up on us.
This is the algorithm
we were aiming to find.
Fast Fourier transform is that
divide and conquer algorithm
on the right.
I'll write it abstractly.
For something called the
DFT-- the discrete Fourier
transform-- is the corresponding
mathematical transformation.
The fast is about an algorithm.
Discrete is about discrete.
So DFT is this thing that
we wanted to compute,
which was basically
the product v times a.
Remember, v was the
Vandermonde matrix,
and it depended
on all these xk's.
And we're going to set xk to
be this e to the ik tau over n.
So if you remember the vjk
here was xj to the k-th power,
so this just becomes e
to the ijk tau over n.
It's a little funny
these are all consecutive
because this is a
totally different,
but-- that's the matrix.
If you take that
matrix times a vector,
that is called a discrete
Fourier transform
of the vector, and FFT is a way
to compute it in n log n time.
You just run this algorithm
and for those xk's it'll
just work in n log n time.
Cool.
But if you remember way back to
the beginning, what we needed
is a way-- this converts
a coefficient vector
into a sample vector.
Then we can multiply
the polynomials,
then we need to transform the
sample vector that results back
into a coefficient vector.
So we're only half done.
I only have 15 minutes.
Luckily, the other half is
almost identical to this half,
so let's do that next.
Maybe over here.
So we've got our great
divide and conquer algorithm,
what we need now--
let me give you
the polynomial
multiplication algorithm.
Let's call this-- sound more
exotic-- fast polynomial
multiplication, fast
meaning n log n.
Let's say that we're
given two polynomials, a
and b, represented
in coefficient form.
What we need is-- I'll
call it a star, which is
the result of running FFT on a.
It's the discrete Fourier
transform of a. b star,
do the same thing.
So we know what this
means is convert
a from a coefficient vector
into a sample vector.
Convert b from a coefficient
vector into a sample vector.
Now I have the samples of a star
at the n-th roots of unity--
these guys-- and
I have the samples
of b at the exact same points--
the n-th roots of unity--
so I can compute c star, the
transform version-- the DFT
of c-- is just the,
I mean, c star k
equals a star k times b star k.
This is the multiplication
algorithm for sample vectors.
We started with that.
That's linear time.
And then the missing
piece is I need
to re-compute c, which is
the inverse fast Fourier
transform of c star.
So this is the missing
link, so to speak.
We need to be able
to go backwards
in this transformation.
Good news is the algorithm
is not going to change.
What we're computing
isn't going to change.
All that's going to
change are the xk's.
Why?
Because, remember
from the top-- right
now we know how to compute
v times a, but what we now
need to compute is
the inverse times a.
So the only question
is, what is the inverse?
This matrix has a super special
structure-- it's symmetric,
lots of points on a
circle-- maybe the inverse
has a nice structure.
And it does.
Claim is the inverse is v
complex conjugate divided by n.
What's complex conjugate?
For a geometer, it's
reflection through the x-axis.
For an algebraic
person, a plus ib,
the complex conjugate
is a minus ib.
So just apply that to
every entry in the matrix,
and then divide all
the entries by n.
You get the inverse.
Cool.
Very cool because what
this tells us is we
run exactly the same
algorithm and do exactly
the same transformation.
If we want to do the
inverse we can actually
just use v, but with a
different choice of xk.
Namely, for the inverse,
we'll call it xk inverse.
We just take the
complex conjugate
of this thing, which
turns out to be
e to the minus ijk
tau over n, and then
divide the whole thing by n.
I'm using a fact here, which
is that the complex conjugate
of this number is
actually, just,
you put a minus sign here.
Why does that hold?
Because geometry.
Theta is usually measuring
the counterclockwise angle
from the x-axis.
If you take the complex
conjugate you go from up here
to down here-- the
reflection to the x-axis.
That's the same thing
as if you measure theta
as a clockwise angle
from the x-axis.
That's the same thing
as negating the angle.
So that's just a
little geometry.
You can prove it
algebraically, although I
don't know how off-hand.
It's not hard.
So if I want to take
some angle and then
flip it through the x-axis,
it's the same as the negative
of the angle.
So the complex
conjugate of this number
is the same thing
with a minus sign.
And then we have to divide by n.
If I just-- did I lie?
I can't divide by n, sorry.
It's in the wrong spot.
I use these xk's and then
I apply the transform.
I take this thing.
I get not quite the inverse, but
I end up getting n the inverse.
I multiply that by my a star.
That's going to
give me n times n.
So then I just take that
vector and divided by n.
Boom, I've got the
inverse transform.
So this is how you do inverse
fast Fourier transform.
You just flip the sign and
the exponent in the xk's,
then you do the same
matrix-vector product,
and then you divide by n.
And then you've
done the inverse.
So that's how you do-- if you
believe this claim-- that's
how you do this last step.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What's the j
in the x j [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE:
Whoops, no j, sorry.
I was imagining these guys.
Just k.
Thank you.
Other questions?
So what remains is
to prove this claim.
I'd be very happy if I-- I
should probably have better--
anyway, that's not the best.
I'm going to call this xk prime.
Then when I plug that in, I get
a different matrix, v prime.
And what this claim
says is that v prime is
equal to n times the inverse.
So I apply the same
f of t algorithm,
but with v prime
instead of v, then I
get not quite the
product I want,
but just n times
the product I want.
Divide every term by n
and we get the inverse.
This is the cool thing
about complex numbers.
Here we get another cool thing.
All right, but we have
to prove this claim.
So let's do a little
bit of algebra.
No pain, no gain.
Good.
So let's look at vjk prime.
Sorry.
So let's look at p,
the product of v,
and v complex conjugate-- what
I was calling v prime up there.
I claim that this thing
is n times the identity
matrix, with 1's
down the diagonal
and 0's everywhere else.
So let's look at this product.
In general, let's look at the
the jk-th item in the product.
That's going to come from row
j of V, dot product with column
k of the complex conjugate.
Now the matrices
here are symmetric,
so actually rows and
columns are the same,
but that's the general
definition of the cell
and the product of two matrices.
So let's write it
out and a summation.
We have-- from m equals
0-- it's so hard not
to use i for my summations.
It's the only class I have to do
it because i is already taken,
but I guess I can
still use capital I,
but we'll use m because i
is complex number today.
So we have e to the i
tau jm over n times e
to the minus i tau mk k over n.
I don't know why I
changed the order.
I put the tau here instead
of there, but same thing.
This is just the
for every position
m in the cell and
corresponding position
m in-- sorry, m in the
row, corresponding position
m in the column, I have
jm and I have mk-- again,
the order doesn't matter.
It's symmetric, but I'm
getting it right here.
This is-- we're
using this formula.
I put a minus sign here because
this is the complex conjugate.
So now I just do some algebra.
These share a lot.
They share i.
They share m, and they
share the divided by n.
So this is sum m equals 0,
n minus 1 e to the i-- oh,
they also share tau-- tau
m over n times j minus k.
Please correct me if
I make any mistakes.
Cool.
So it depends how and
k relate, of course.
If j equals k, that's also known
as something on the diagonal.
I want the matrix
n, n, n, n, 0, 0.
So j equals k.
That's the diagonal.
That's where I want to get n,
and, indeed, if j equals k,
this becomes 0.
So all this becomes
0. e to the 0 is 1,
and so I'm summing up 1 n times.
I get n.
Cool.
That's one case.
This is n if j equals k, and
somehow I claim that everywhere
else I get 0's.
So let's prove that.
So if j does not
equal k-- I'm going
to rewrite this a little bit.
j and k are fixed.
m is changing in the sum,
so I want to write this
as sum m equals 0 to n minus
1, e to the i tau j minus k,
over m, times m.
In other words, this thing
raised to the n-th power.
What is this series?
One word.
AUDIENCE: Geometric.
ERIK DEMAINE: Geometric.
Thank you.
This is a geometric
series, and I
guess I should have waited to
give you the Frisbee until you
tell me how do you
solve a geometric series
with a finite term?
So think of this as z to the m.
Do you know the formula?
AUDIENCE: That's
the e to the i tau--
ERIK DEMAINE: Just z.
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh,
z to the n minus 1.
ERIK DEMAINE: Z
to the n minus 1.
Almost.
AUDIENCE: Over z minus 1.
ERIK DEMAINE: Over z minus 1.
Yep.
That's-- If you have sum of z to
the k, k equals 0 to n minus 1.
That's that.
It's in the appendix
of your textbook.
So we just plug
that in and we get--
oh boy-- e to the-- better
chalk-- e to the i tau
j minus k over n to the n-th
power minus 1 over e to the i.
Actually, the denominator
doesn't really
matter because this
is supposed to be 0,
so it's all about the numerator,
but it's the same thing.
Minus 1.
Where's my red?
Red.
The n cancels with the n.
This is an integer not equal to
zero, so we have e to the i tau
to an integer power.
What's e to the i tau?
1.
Convenient that I
have that there.
1 minus 1 is 0, so we get 0.
Satisfying.
So that proves this claim.
We prove that, on the
diagonal, we get n
because we had n copies of 1.
Off the diagonal we
get 0, like this.
Therefore, v complex conjugate
times n is the v inverse.
Therefore, this
algorithm actually
computes the inverse
fast Fourier transform.
So that's it for
algorithms today,
but let me quickly tell you
about some applications.
You've probably
taken other classes
that use applications of
fast Fourier transform,
so I will just summarize.
If you've ever edited
audio, you probably
did it in-- unless you're just
pasting audio clips together--
you probably did it in what's
called frequency space.
So you know that-- as I talked
about in the beginning--
when we're measuring where the
membrane on this microphone
goes over time, that is in
the time domain for every time
we sample where,
physically, this thing is.
If you apply-- I think
the way I defined it here
is the inverse fast
Fourier transform,
usually it's called Fourier
transform-- to that time domain
vector, you get a new vector.
Now it's a complex vector.
You may have started
with real numbers.
You get complex numbers.
So for every position
in the vector--
what it corresponds to-- the
x-axis is no longer time.
Now it's frequency.
For every frequency
you're measuring,
essentially, you're
viewing this vector--
the waveform-- as a bunch
of trigonometric functions--
say, sine of
something times theta.
If you look at one of the
entries in the vector,
and it's a complex
number-- if you compute
the magnitude of
the complex number--
the length of the
vector, of the length
of that two-coordinate vector--
that is how much stuff--
of that frequency-- you have.
And then the angle
of the vector, in 2D,
is how that trigonometric
function shifted in time.
So if you take a pure note,
like if I was playing a bell
and it's exactly C major,
it looks really wavy.
It's actually a
nice perfect sine
curve-- some offset
depending on when I hit it--
and then if you apply the
Fourier transform what you get
is 0's everywhere except for the
one frequency that's appearing,
and there you get 1, and
everywhere else you get 0.
Well, 1 possibly rotated,
depending on the phase.
And you can take
any audio stream,
convert it by a
Fourier transform,
do manipulations there.
For example, you've probably
heard of high-pass filters that
removes all the
high frequencies,
or low-pass filters remove
all of the low frequencies.
You just convert to
this space and zero out
the parts you want, and
then you convert back
with inverse Fourier transform.
If you've used Adobe
Audition or Audacity,
they can all do these things.
And there are tons
of contexts where
converting to Fourier
space makes life easy.
And, in general, if you
have any time-based signal
you should always think about
what do you get with FFT
when you transform to
frequency-based signal,
and you can do
lots of cool things
you couldn't do otherwise.
And it only takes n log n time.
Plus people do it in hardware.
There's a fast
implementation called
FFTW-- the fastest Fourier
transform in the west-- which
is made here at MIT
a bunch of years ago,
and is still the best software
implementation of FFT.
So people use it everywhere.
Your noise-cancelling headsets
probably use it, MP3 uses it.
It's a cool algorithm.